to
is it life
oh we're live hello hello and good to
see everyone at today's book club part 5
May 1st 3 p.m. on the East Coast good to
see you all thanks for being here
lots of good book clubs both some
familiar ones and some new ones some new
ones the aspiration catalyst business
book club nice to see you team USA I
thank you here last week nice to see you
again app men book club from Brazil
lovely to see you also representing from
Zambia India Rio de Janeiro Auckland
Belgium Anchorage Ghana it's a
combination of countries and cities and
a happy birthday to Amon it's your
birthday today so wish you a happy
birthday when the announcement that I
need to share what I need any more
birthdays hello from Orlando Florida
Glasgow Scotland the Bailiwick book club
in Minnesota good to see you Peru Texas
good to see you all Sydney it's got to
be really early in the morning there
isn't it as you know it's been 10 years
since start with why came out and my
publisher said would you do a 10-year
anniversary edition which means that I
had to reread the whole thing and update
it and clarify some things and I thought
well why should I read it alone why not
it's way more fun to read it with other
people and that's where we hatched this
tidy a--to do book club the whole idea
was not actually to read the book it was
to bring people together in a time where
we are socially isolated the whole idea
is to read a book with friends discuss
the book and then we all come together
once a week to talk about it here you've
sent in a bunch of questions online
thank you for pre submitting the
questions and we're gonna take some live
questions as well next week will be our
last book club part six on Friday it'll
be on Friday
may 10th and 3:00 p.m. be very very sad
okay let me tell you some thoughts that
I had about about this section I
actually really like this section you
know a lot of the previous sections are
about the the what makes the Golden
Circle how to use it what it looks like
you know the form it takes we had the
cone last week and this really was watch
a very practical section that got a
little more into sort of the a little
more into that how it actually works I
also really appreciated this it touched
upon and I'd sort of forgotten about
this the difference between being
successful and feeling successful that
they're not always the same things and a
lot of people who can measure they're
the the trappings of success we usually
measure this stuff in money but that
doesn't necessarily correspond with the
feeling and one of the things that I
think has been so special about these
strange coded times is I think that we
have been forced as a society to really
re-evaluate our definition of success
this is affecting everybody around the
world and I think that you know the
people who have been anxious about being
productive for example I think that is
an old definition of success that we had
to be productive all the time so that we
can make more things that we can count
our success and I think we've been
forced to slow down and actually see
that success comes in different ways it
comes in spending times with family
it comes in taking the time to build
close personal meaningful relationships
all of these things take time away from
productivity we're living like it's the
1950s now the good the good stuff where
if you're at home with your family we're
having family dinner every night this is
kind of a magical thing and all of these
things that are very good for our health
very good for our mental health very
good for our feeling of success don't
necessarily translate into into the
productivity of success so I really like
that and it really talked about how the
concept of why helps us find that
feeling of success and be less less
fixated on
counting stuff ironically or not so
ironically that when we focus on why we
do what we do we're more likely to
actually enjoy commercial success as
well and it comes a little it comes with
a little more passion than stress to
people that I wrote about that
I remember them when I when I met them
Christina harborage and Dwayne honoré
absolutely loved how they went counted
to they acted counted to intuition
counted to come and belief to bring
their cause to life Christina harborage
started a collections agency collections
agencies are usually you usually
incentivize your people based on how
much money you collect when you're
collecting debts
Christina believes in being a good
person treating people right that
everybody has a story and she broke with
convention with everything that every
business mind would tell her that she
had to do and she incentivized her
people based on how many thank-you cards
they sent out because it was more
important to her that her collections
agents listened to the people they were
on the phone with rather than
threatening them and as the book
revealed her results were three hundred
percent better than the industry average
I absolutely love that that though there
are conventions on how we need to build
our businesses or how I need to grow our
careers or live our lives nobody says
that those conventions are correct
they're just conventional that just
common and over the years a lot of those
conventions have become shorter and
shorter term focus so it was really nice
to reconnect with the fact that doing
things that we believe are right for us
even though they may buck the system
sometimes is worth the risk and in
Christina's case even though she was
ready to make less money she was she
decided that was the right way to do
things she ended up making more money
Dwayne honoré the other one Dwayne
honoré runs a construction company in
Baton Rouge Louisiana and believes in
family values believes in that he
believes what we're experiencing now
he's always believed this that it's the
right thing to do to go home and have
dinner with your family
he believes in things like that and so
one of the ways he helped force that
behavior was telling people that they
had to clock out from his construction
company they had to clock out between
5:00 and 5:30 in the in the evening and
if they didn't clock out on time they
would
sacrifice their bonuses and so everybody
showed up on time 8:00 to 8:30 and
everybody left on time 5 to 5:30 and he
suffered zero productivity losses I
think the lesson there is is when we
have to get our work done we get our
work done and when our bosses and our
companies say we think it's important
that you spend time with your family so
you better get your work done before you
go home to your family
we get it done it also I think proves
does how much time we waste in the day
when we're giving unlimited amounts of
time to work the other studies done with
executives based on how much time they
work and and a group of executives we're
told that they had to go home I can
remember the exact exact time you know
6:00 or 6:30 and the other set of
executives could could work however long
and however late they wanted to like
they always did and lo and behold the
ones who went in went home earlier not
only were as productive they were more
productive than they're then they're
then they're late working brethren so I
really appreciated this chapter and a
good reminder of the split that and I
think that again these kovat times
remind us that high-flying financial
success means absolutely nothing when
there are sudden unexpected events and
by the way there are always a sudden
unexpected events not always this grand
scale but there are always things that
happen based on marketplaces or new
technologies or culture or politics or
something sometimes what our competition
does and the question is how do we react
and the best way to react is to be
proactive in other words to have a sense
of foundation of where you're starting
from and go out I back to be getting
lots of questions lately about this
about how do we pivot our businesses how
to pivot our careers and the way to do
it is with a givers heart which is
instead of saying well how do we make
more money in this environment rather
the better way to say is how do we take
all the things we have and bring and and
and find ways to give them to world to
the world in new ways if we have if we
believe we have things of value how do
we share them with the outside world you
wonderful people who've been here on
book club have know that we've been
going through this exact pivot you were
the wonderful
early adopters the the beta testers of
our of our jumpstart your y course
thanks for crashing our website by the
way and and because of your help and
because we believed we had something of
value we wanted to test it out we are
now offering it on a weekly basis we're
really proud of this we're really proud
that we're doing things in a new way but
we're doing them with the givers heart
and all of the courses that we've now
started offering on on our website have
all been based on the people we've
called for help or people who've called
us and it's all the stuff that we have
personally found value in and we thought
the right thing to do was to share with
as many people as possible should we
take some of your questions should we do
that okay questions hello from London
hello from Orlando hello from Ann Arbor
Michigan lots of people here today good
to see you all lots of questions okay
let's get aware my list of questions
here they are okay question number one
from Rome Italy from Elvis from Elvis
and Christina
lvo did I say that right what do you do
if you co founded a firm together with a
business partner based on a shared why
but after 10 years your partner seems to
have lost the original why how do you
manage the situation and how do you
continue to realize your why if every
day you have a different view from your
partner I assume that this is a
theoretical question so theoretically
speaking if you have a business with
someone and they have forgotten the
reason why you founded it one of the
ways to do it and by the way I've gone
through this but one of the ways to to
do it is to sit down with your partner
and say can we talk about the reason why
we started this business together do you
remember when and and you want to
reminisce and what you find is a lot of
times organizations who've gone through
the split sometimes it's both parties
sometimes it's all parties sometimes
it's one party that's you know it's not
that that person never had the why
because you wouldn't started the
business with them I assume and you had
many good years where you were
passionate together the
is what happened that made them lose it
was that that they're stressed out was
that that the money got good and they
forgotten the reason they became more
obsessed with protecting or making more
money and so one of the nice things to
do is go out for dinner make it social
and reminisce and and talk about it in
terms not of we have a problem with our
partnership but in talk about in terms
of remember how magical it was when we
started and this was the same experience
that I learned when I sat down with
those gathering of titans all of these
highly highly successful people who'd
completely fallen out of love with their
own work who've Lots their passion
didn't feel successful and very often
all it took was a reminder a
conversation and a bunch of questions I
would ask them what was it that was so
special when you had no money you're
working out of a garage you know you
were living paycheck to paycheck it was
stressful you were working late hours
your whole family had to help
and yet you crave those times you
reminisce about those times what was so
special and what you'll find out almost
always it's the people it wasn't the
excessive amounts of hard work it's not
that we enjoyed scraping together money
to pay our bills none of that stuff is
fun what made it fun was that we did it
with others that we that we had a shared
experience was the camaraderie so so to
avez EO and and Cristina I would
recommend going out for a dinner or
lunch maybe not now maybe wait a little
bit or do it over zoom and just have a
conversation and reminisce and see if
you can reinstate question if there's a
split that occurs what kind of how types
do to help the organization get back to
why same thing same thing is the answer
I just gave a moment ago which is to go
go to those leaders go to if you can if
you have access go to those those Y
folks and say can I tell you why I love
this company can I tell you why I love
this job you're speaking in a very
emotional terms you're saying I'm gonna
tell you why not what so we already know
that it's gonna be something a little
more emotion
and we're saying why I love this
organization and what inspires me about
this organization again sometimes our
leaders go through the split it's
because they've forgotten not because
they're bad people it's because they
become distracted it happens to everyone
it happens to everyone and the question
is how quickly can we get back before we
produce a lot of cultural change and and
screw up our incentive structures and
hire the wrong people
so a great way to go do it is to tell
somebody why you love the company and
why why you why you are still loyal this
is when I remember roaming the halls of
Microsoft years and years ago talking to
people who used to reminisce about the
good old days after the organization had
gone through the split but they could
easily say why they love the company
even if they were talking about the past
so yeah go go and go and tell them why
you left the company you'll find that it
has an amazing thing okay Doug has a
police question how would you suggest I
help my new police supervisors inspire
their people to rediscover their
personal why and bring back the pride in
the service when many officers feel
beaten down and wish to give up and have
checked out thanks for your question
Doug so one of the things that I think
police forces are struggling with today
is the same thing that many
organizations are struggling with today
which is over the years the culture of
policing has become more obsessed with
metrics just like in business and
business we've seen the steady trend
that that business has become more
obsessed with metrics and shorter
shorter term time frames at the
sacrifice of their why and the sacrifice
of their culture and the sacrifice of
loving coming to work the same thing
because it's a cultural thing it's
affecting politics is affecting business
and it's affecting public service and so
police forces are the same you know
better than I do the the obsession that
that are the civilian oversight puts on
a police force they think that they're
measuring crime based on tickets written
and arrests made which of course is
nonsense
that's that is a metric but it's not the
metric and so one of the things we have
to do is remember that that there are
human beings who come into work every
day and if they don't feel like they can
trust each other and Trust leadership
then that increases the amount of stress
and in private sector if we see people
suffer extreme amounts of stress at work
they take it out on their kids they take
it out on their spouse and it may affect
how they perform at work well guess what
happens in the police force they take it
out on each other they take it out on
their spouses they take it on their kids
and in the case of policing in extreme
cases we give someone authority and a
gun extreme stress shows up in horrible
horrible ways and I think we need to
have more empathy for the fact that
they're going through something that's
very very similar in other police forces
so I recommend checking out the work of
Castle Rock Police Department Chief Jack
collie he's the chief out there he came
into a similar situation a pretty
traditional police force metrics driven
arrests and tickets written and he
completely transformed his police force
Jack collie out in Castle Rock Colorado
and he focused exclusively on how his
officers felt when they came to work and
he's seen a dramatic shift in the
culture and the and the quality of the
relationship he has with the community
as well they're human beings and think
about how they feel when they come to
work I hope that helps grapevine book
club hello grapevine book club apart
from there why what are universal traits
of a good CEO and leader it is important
that a successor come from inside the
organization so the I get this question
a lot sort of what what are the what are
the characteristics of a good leader a
good CEO the one you know charisma
vision I know some great leaders not
they don't have big Steve Jobs visions I
know some great leaders that they don't
they don't have tons of energy when
they're bouncing down down down the
halls we redefine charisma versus energy
and in this book that charisma is
undying belief they definitely all have
that but the one character
characteristic I'm very very comfortable
saying that
every great leader that I've had the
opportunity to meet or learn about they
all share is courage because it is very
very hard to be a good leader it comes
at great personal sacrifice sometimes
the benefits are not realized for a long
period of time it's a lot like exercise
you know that when you're working out or
eating healthy you don't see the results
on a daily basis but you have to have
the discipline to commit to the process
and good leadership is the same you have
to have the discipline to commit to the
process even if the results are not
obvious immediately especially when
there's tremendous amounts of pressure
sometimes internally even to do the
short-term thing to do the expedient
thing as opposed to doing the right
thing so it takes tremendous courage and
the other thing is integrity because
courage without integrity is is a scary
thing the the the having integrity and
staying true to the cause and and an
ethics we're seeing this happen right
now in the United States our government
has given at small business loans PPP
loans to help small businesses stay in
business and what we've seen is a huge
number of well I read a report this
morning a billion dollars has been given
out to public companies some of whom are
our highly successful organizations who
have other means of raising monies to
help them to help them stay afloat and
the party line from every single one of
those companies who should not have been
who should not have accepted those loans
or even applied for them is is that we
were just following the rules and the
law allowed us to well that doesn't mean
it was a fickle just because it was a
hastily written rule a hastily written
law where they didn't consider all of
the components just because the the the
the letter of the law allows you to
doesn't mean you should that's what
integrity looks like when you look at
and say we could apply but we're not
going to because it would deny people
who need it more than us from getting it
so I think it's despicable that
companies that have applied for the PPP
loan who did not need it and did not
deserve it did it anyway and claimed
that they weren't breaking any laws I
wrote a whole chapter about that in the
infinite game
about ethical fading and unfortunately
we're seeing about live so courage
integrity and is it important that a
successor to come from inside the
organization no not at all
you're more likely to get someone who
believes in the cause and who
understands the culture and who is
driven by the cause if they have come up
through the company that's more likely
but but it's not it's not a necessity
you can absolutely have people come from
outside the organization what's
essential is that whatever they were
doing prior has similar a similar cause
or similar belief set as to what they're
doing now so for example let's say
Southwest Airlines was looking for a new
CEO where should they look of course
internal a lot of their people have come
up through the ranks but they don't have
to and so what's traditional is they'll
go and look in the airline business and
they'll go hire some former airline
executive and make them the CEO of their
airline but the cause will be different
because not all airlines run like
Southwest Airlines they are more likely
to get a better CEO at Southwest
Airlines if they hired somebody from
Dunkin Donuts for example because
they're both everyman companies they're
both who believe in in empower to to the
M to the everyman to the average working
stiff and and being the champion for the
common man like you're more likely to
get the belief set and they'll learn the
airline business it's a whole company
filled with people who understand the
airline business what we need at the top
is somebody to lead the cause so they
don't have to come from inside but they
you if you go outside you have to ensure
that they are devotees to the movement
oh I like this one The Hague Byrd's book
club I have been to Den Haag it is very
pretty there so The Hague Bear Byrd's
book club asks what can management do if
their shareholders with hire and fire
powers define success as cash in the
next quarter while employees and
customers who transform the Y into
what's that matter for daily life define
it as positive impact well that goes
back to courage again doesn't it what
can marinate management do if the
shareholders with higher power defines
success as the short term there is
safety in numbers and if one manager
attempts to stand up to the shareholders
that manager will very likely lose their
job but it's very difficult to fire the
entire management team especially when
you're preaching a cause of doing the
right thing and doing something for the
long term and believing in the long term
integrity stability and resilience of
the organization because we are in a
very good time right now for these kinds
of messages during the 1980s we could
not have gotten away with this but for a
management team to stand up and say that
shareholders are preoccupied only with
short-term gains and we believe that the
shareholder will benefit more if they
allow us to build a strong stable
company as opposed to just milking it
for the short term and we believe this
is the right thing to do in business if
they're willing to do it in together if
they're willing to stand up in numbers
it makes it more difficult for them all
to get fired at once it also is
embarrassing for the shareholders
some sort of but this is a shareholders
to do that but unfortunately this is
what happens when we have what are they
called
no no no the kinds of investors that
come in and screw everything up what do
they call Raiders you know corporate
raiders they have a name I forgot my
name I'm looking at the cons to see if
somebody can help me here but corporate
raiders like car-like and they come in
and they they they do just that and
unfortunately those companies we hope
that they can survive for the long term
sometimes they don't but the same thing
the courage and you have to have the
clarity of message what I find very
often also is sometimes well-intentioned
executives aren't able to communicate
their cause and so it just comes across
as as defense it just comes across as
reactive or angry but if we provide
clear context of why we believe what we
believe why we're doing were doing to
remember that example in the book
earlier in the book about the young man
who goes on a date and he gaves the
gives the context why he loves why he
loves his job and makes him more
appealing same thing here communication
no matter to whom where the internal or
external when it starts with Y is way
way way more powerful so before any
executive is willing to stand up they
have to start with why it absolutely
helps set the context what else we take
a live question let's see
we got here leaders are readers book
club in India how are you what are the
best ways to change the culture in the
organization you were working for I love
this question
so if you're working for an organization
that is what focused and you want to
make the help make the organization why
focused the way you do it is you be the
leader you wish you had we cannot
control that that which we cannot
control we can only control that which
we can control and if we cannot control
our environments what we can control is
ourselves Viktor Frankl 101 there man's
search for meaning if you hadn't read
and ran search for meaning please read
it it's essential reading for every
human being and this is what Viktor
Frankl taught us if we cannot change the
world around us we can change ourselves
and and the way to change a corporate
structure when you are not the person at
the top is to be the leader you wish you
had that we take care of the people to
the left of us and to the right of us we
work hard to see that those around us
will succeed and grow as individuals and
feel that someone has their back and
what you start to see is these little
teams become higher performing teams
inside the organizations themselves and
when they're higher performing because
they're better quality teams senior
management either leaves them alone or
if they're well-intentioned senior
management leans in and says hey what
are you guys doing
and when those people leave and get
promoted or move to other teams they
take everything they've learned about
leadership to those other teams and they
start building good teams over there and
before you know it the tail wags the dog
it can be done I had the pleasure of
working with a very very large
organization over a hundred thousand
people and we had no access to senior
leadership and we had middle management
that wanted to change the course of the
culture for good they believed in the
origin story they believed in the why
senior leadership gotten away from it
they've gone through a split and this is
what started to happen and within two
years which I thought was very quick for
an organization that size senior
leadership was giving speeches with the
words that these middle managers were
using and none of them had a meeting
with senior leadership because it
bubbles up the tail can wag the dog we
don't always have control over the time
frames this is one other thing about law
of diffusion which is a hundred percent
it works but we don't exactly know when
the tipping point happens
and in most businesses because they like
to have definitive answers at the end of
the year at the end of the quarter
they don't embrace philosophies like the
law of diffusion because they want
certainty they want control well you can
have control if you play short-term if
you're willing to accept the
responsibility for the long term damage
I've always been more comfortable using
goals and annual markers as guidelines
yes we drive very hard towards our
deadlines yes we drive very hard forward
hour towards our goals but the most
important thing is that we see that
we're improving along the way and if we
miss the goal as long as we see constant
improvement we're gonna hit the goal in
another month
we're tend to be pretty relaxed about it
because we understand law of diffusion
and the way that these things work is
sometimes the the things we achieve or
not easily measurable so if you're
willing to be patient and accept that we
don't know the exact time frames as to
when you can shift the culture it is a
fantastic it is a fantastic strategy to
follow the why Warriors w AR are are
they warriors who are warriors WI
warriors book club yes about
organizations that give the question was
any more examples about organizations
that that change their incentive
structures based on why versus what will
Doug us the policing question I Castle
Rock Police Department in in Castle Rock
Colorado Jack collie changed the way he
incentivized his his officers instead of
based on arrests or tickets written it's
based on problems solved because he
wants them to solve problems one by one
so I'll give you an example there's a
lot of car accidents in a particular
intersection this is a true story
the way a traditional police force would
handle it is they would go and put an
officer by that by that intersection and
give out more tickets that officer would
get a reward because the tickets went up
but will they actually stop car
accidents no of course not maybe only
for the short time when the
and they're giving out tickets but
because chief Kali said I want you to
solve problems not just write tickets
the officers went at went at it with a
completely different point of view
instead of trying to just put a bandaid
on it they thought what can we do to
solve the problem they reached out to
the Department of Transportation
officers don't usually reach out to the
Department of Transportation and they
arranged to put stop signs in so they
put stop signs in unfortunately they
wrote no tickets now so that metric
plummeted but they stopped the car
accidents they dramatically reduced the
number of car accidents in that
intersection they got a bonus they got a
reward they got recognized for solving a
problem that's a good example there's a
company that gives bonuses that that
value adds bonus is based on
contribution to culture and contribution
to revenues 5050 next jump in New York
City so if you're only a revenue driven
person if you only care about the money
they'll give you 50% of your bonus if
all you do is walk around every day in
making sure everyone's okay they'll give
you 50% of your bonus so they want
people to be doubly concerned with with
with with taking care of the culture but
also but also protecting the the
longevity and the financial stability of
the organization barry-wehmiller company
I've written about a lot there's a lot
of they have something called the the
SSI program where what they do is
completely voluntary people submit they
nominate their colleagues and co-workers
for recognition and the standard is that
these people uphold our values better
than anyone else and we aspire to be
more like them it's not done by by
leadership it's not a top-down
evaluation it's it's it's across the
board
it's it's voluntary and they and a group
of volunteers take all the nominations
read all the nominations their essays
they're not just like I nominate Steve
write their full essays and they go and
meet all the people to see what they're
like and then they this committee will
choose someone who they believe best
embodies the company's values and who we
all want to be like they have a big
event where they invite all employees
everybody stops working for this moment
and they announce who we all want to be
more
like who embodies our values most they
read some of the letters that were
written in there's always tears and they
bring their families in their their
parents to come and they sneak them in a
secretly so when they announce the
winner the the families brought in to
see the kind of child that they raised
there is always crying there's always
tears but the reason they do this is
because this company believes in you
know it's a it's a culture where we take
care of each other
it's a culture where we recognize each
other and it's a culture of camaraderie
and teamwork and so they needed to have
an effective peer review system to
recognize that not just top down where
one person says you're a good evaluator
you know you're I mean you're a good
representation of our of our of our
values we don't know maybe they just
manage up really well so that's a good
one about my banana t-shirt okay so
these came from our from our tour I'll
tell you why we did them so we have a
thing when I when I when I when I was on
the mindset tour we have a QA and
sometimes what happens when you do live
QA in an audio with an audience is some
people mistake asking questions to
giving soliloquies and so we needed a
nice way a polite way to say can we get
to the question please or if they've
asked the question but they keep asking
and asking it to sort of say to
interrupt we've all had this experience
where we've been in a meeting and
somebody makes a point and we all
understand and they just keep talking
and talking and talking and talking and
we're all sitting there and none of us
wants in to interrupt because we don't
to be rude but they're just going on and
on and on and on and about at the same
point that we all already understand
that well in our company we came up with
this idea of banana so when someone is
talking about something completely
unrelated to the meeting we're having or
if they're going on and on and on about
something that we already understand
somebody in the room will go banana
which is just a polite way of saying you
stop talking please we understand and so
we thought it'd be really fun to have
t-shirts made that say banana to remind
people I understand I get it
we if you want one we have a if you go
to our shop simon Sinek comm you click
on shop I think there's a little thing
that we put a swag have you check out
our swag we have the banana t-shirts so
bananas a big cultural thing for us in
our company it's really fun and it's a
much easier way to interrupt people so
we can get to the point it helps make
meetings go quicker and nobody gets
offended because of banana so I guess
technically you could banana me if my
answers are too long you could say
banana and if I happen to see it I'll
stop okay banana let's move on you
understand what else do we have here any
other live questions let's take a look
here's one from the Peggy page turners I
like it why can't why a Y can become
fuzzy over time true individuals can
lose sight in the haze created by the
everyday demands ie what and how
absolutely true how do we reaffirm why
even if we haven't realized that the
connection has been lost ah such a good
question and a very real human challenge
and and by the way I struggle with it as
well I wrote the book about why and I
too sometimes find myself getting a
little fuzzy there's multiple ways to
guard against it I recommend all of them
I've done all of them and continue to do
all them number one this one's really
easy surround yourself with references
and symbols of your why I don't just
wear these t-shirts
some of them say inspire some of them
say optimist they're not just fun
they're actually reminders to me because
for me to add the word inspire or
optimist or or the color orange I use
the color orange for on purpose because
it's the color of optimism these are all
reminders to me these are all symbols
that remind me of what I stand for we
wear we're coming we're familiar with
these things religious iconography a lot
of people wear religious icons around
neck's well it's a reminder to ourselves
of our values and what we stand for and
why we get out of bed in the morning I
print out I'd have a label maker I print
out my favorite quotes and I stick them
on desks in my bedside table my bedside
table has a quote on it from Henry Ford
that says if you think you can or you
think you can't you're right
or was it Thomas Edison no it's Henry
Ford if you think you can or you think
you can't you're right that's there to
remind me I I buy things that have
orange in them I have shoes with orange
laces I have belts with orange I have
the word inspire embroidered into my
jeans in orange these are all reminders
I have shirts that say inspire
embroidered on them they're all
reminders for me they're all reminders
for me that when I get dressed in the
morning I see the color I see the
symbols I see the words to remind me why
I do what I do the other thing you got
to have is really close relationships
with people who care about you so that
if you're going a little bit hazy or
fuzzy somebody says to you I think
you're off your game or there's
something different or there's something
wrong or there's not this is not like
you and so sometimes we don't have
objectivity on ourselves but others have
objectivity over us so more objectivity
of us so so you want people who love you
and care about you both friends and
colleagues to watch out just as we're
doing for them and and little reminders
surround yourself with little reminders
pictures people that inspire you any
kind of symbol of your cause in fact I
would always recommend am I gonna get
been on it here because I'm going on and
on about the same answer I've got
bananas yet I'll just keep talking when
I would do why discoveries for people
they would one of their childhood
stories that they would share I would
have them buy a knick-knack or a thing
that reminds them of their childhood
story to put in their desks so I have
one friend my friend Matthew we did his
why his childhood story involved sailing
boats so I had him buy a small sailing
boat and put it on his desk somebody
else's involved I don't know beaches I
had them have a beach scene from that
from that childhood story you know
hanging on their walls you got to do
this stuff you know you've got to be
surrounded by reminders
activist investors Thank You Kurt that
is exactly who I was trying to remember
before it was active investors thank you
those are the Titans the the berra the
rubber barons okay from Graz Austria and
Athens Greece so day-to-day habits to
keep you reminded on your why and not
have the day-to-day complexity
interrupts that's it that's a you know
the problem with habits is once they
become habit habitual then they blend in
um in some cities here you'll see
speeding signs or have changed so for
example it used to say a you know or
just any kind of enforcement sign you
know if you litter of five hundred
dollars or if you drive in the HOV line
five two hundred two hundred dollars and
the problem is we're so used to seeing
round numbers that our brains literally
don't see them anymore and so what they
started doing is you know driving HOV
Lane fine three hundred and fifty one
dollars or litter find 128 dollars and
these random numbers and what it does is
it makes us look so habits are are
useful if they have meaning but they're
not useful if they just become part of a
morning routine like we could say that
brushing your teeth in the morning
should be a reminder of being healthy
and eating healthy every day how many of
us actually think brushing our teeth
reminds us that we should eat celery
later on it's not gonna happen right
because it's it's just too much but
anything that that keeps you grounded
reminding of your why I'm a big fan of
if you meditate I'm a big fan of
meditation I think that's a good daily
habit to start the day a a few a few
sort of um a few sort of my mind's not
working today what do you call it with a
tuning fork you know what are those
called a few a few a few levels lower
take it down a notch yeah it take it
down and it's things that because the
the things that distract us the frenetic
pace you know the the constant
bombardment of numbers and what and
requests and emails and so we can reduce
the noise we now have mental space to
remind ourselves of the why so reduce
noise stop hitting reply all in all of
your emails why because what we're doing
is making noise for other people who
can't focus on why and just as we all
struggle with our inboxes and we're
struggling to come up with a strategy to
reduce our inboxes as an active service
we can stop hitting reply all like what
time's the meeting can't wait to be
there didn't you just that's an email I
never needed to read ever thank you
thank you and so I have 400 emails to
get through in a day because 150 or 200
or 300 of them are completely
unnecessary so one of the ways we can
help everyone around us find that space
is to send fewer emails pick up the
phone more often hey how you doing can I
just respond to your question that helps
people find space and as we're learning
in these kovat times fewer texts few
emails and more blank space is a
wonderful thing go for a walk
don't take your phone go out for dinner
don't take your phone and you'll find
yourself connecting with your purpose a
lot easier when we have space here's a
question who's your meditation teacher
that's a good one here's what I did when
I learned to meditation meditation was
becoming a thing so I thought whoo I
like things I better I better find out
what this thing is all about I tend to
do that when things start to be popular
I tend to sign up for them join them I
signed up for snapchat just to see what
the hubbub was about but then I deleted
it that was that is not for me
but I sign up for things because I want
to know I want to know what the
conversations about I want to be able to
speak educated ly about them so I didn't
know anything about meditation and so I
started as might what I tend to do is I
ask my friends so I started asking every
some of my friends do you meditate I was
blown away how many of my friends had a
regular meditation practice people I
never expected it had regular meditation
practices and so I'd ask them all
what do you do how do you meditate
because I tried the apps and I tried
things that didn't really work for me
but I asked all my friends what they did
and basically what I did is I took I
took the best pieces all the things that
I liked the most from all of my friends
and put it together and made my own one
so my teacher were all my friends and
they were all wonderful and helpful and
I took what I liked and threw away what
I didn't like and it worked out well
meditate what was the question again
ah
a great question the question was how
can we spark conversations about the
silver linings during this this pandemic
just like that can I tell you one of the
silver linings in this in this pandemic
is a great way to start that
conversation the great thing about the
term silver lining is it is just that a
silver lining it is in a cloud and so it
doesn't deny reality and it means you
don't have to feel guilty saying
something positive or optimistic when
there's struggle and suffering around us
because as a it is a silver lining and
the world is always made up of balance
where there is bad there is good and
where there is good there is bad nature
abhors a vacuum and there's always
opportunity in in tragedy and there is
and there always there's always hubris
and and blindness that comes in in
success as well and so I I've been doing
this a lot with people and and for
anybody who follows me on Instagram I
I've made a decision
that I that my Instagram feed and the
things that I post won't be educational
in other words I didn't post any videos
about how to wash your hands that's
important but lots of people are doing
it and that message will get out
somewhere else I I decided that what I
will do is share those silver linings
little nuggets that I've seen or come
across that I think helped remind us
that there are some good things that are
coming out of this and here are some of
the good things
relationships are getting stronger in
some cases where we
connecting with people we haven't talked
to in a while we're having conversations
over the phone this tone of voice and
we're reminded of the value of family
we're reminded of the value of space
we're reminded the value of patience
we're reminded the value of each other
we're also reminded of the the fragility
of our economies our countries our of
life itself and and I think whenever
human beings suffer tragedy whether it's
personal tragedy in our families or or
international tragedy global tragedy
like this
I think we're reminded that life is
short and to and to savor every single
day because who knows what's going to
happen literally tomorrow this was so
sudden and I and I hope that the lessons
we're learning last my fear is that
we'll forget them but but I think it is
important for us to share silver linings
with each other and and to start just
that way you know the silver lining in
this cloud and then say it because it's
a beautiful thing and I've had some
online dinner parties with a couple of
friends and one of us did that and the
whole conversation was positive the
whole conversation was that the stuff
we've learned about ourselves and an
amazing dinner party recently with some
wonderful friends and one of us said can
I tell you something that I that I'm
actually enjoying about this this
pandemic which was a very funny turn of
phrase to use but there was some and we
all started talking about the stuff that
we were appreciating we're learning
about ourselves as individuals as as as
brothers as sisters as as husbands as as
wives as friends we're learning where we
have room to improve we're learning
things that we strengths we have that we
didn't know we had I think it's I think
it's a really important thing to talk
about somebody just been on at me what
else do we have here
i express itself as a young man before
yeah so my why is to inspire people to
do the things that inspire them so that
each of us can change our world for the
better together so together each of us
can change our world for the better
which is why you see inspiration built
everywhere so how did my wife before I
was able to articulate it so the thing
that is so all of us have a Y and our Y
will naturally show up whether we know
it or not the problem is it's it's like
a game of roulette that sometimes you're
in the flow and sometimes you're not the
problem is how do you make sure you can
turn that on that's very difficult we've
all had experiences where everything we
touch turns to gold and no matter how
hard we're working we're passionate
that's because our Y is present we've
also had the experience we were doing
the exact same thing that we've always
done and yet this time it's more of a
struggle and more difficult than it ever
has been it's because the Y isn't there
and so a Y captures who we are the whole
golden circle rather captures who we are
when we are working at our natural best
so prior to me articulating my why there
were random occurrences where I felt
inspired and I was loving it and my
friends would say to me you're so
inspiring or that was so that thing you
did was really inspiring and I felt good
but I never knew that it was a thing I
just thought they were paying me a nice
compliment and it would just like
everybody else these times would happen
fairly randomly and since I've been able
to articulate my why I know that that's
a thing that I'm supposed to focus on
it's a thing that I'm supposed to build
what's out of so no matter what I write
no matter what we know what it says on
our website no matter what it says on my
t-shirt no matter you know it says
banana but it's in orange and we got our
little flame on the back you can't see
it but it's a little our little flame
that ignites on the back
no commercialization if you know because
I can't stand commercialization on
things this is because these are not for
me therefore the the people who wear
them this is all important but the point
is is all of these things are super
super super super focused and I'm much
better at ensuring that I'm in that
sense of flow and more inspired more
often imperfect but more often because
I'm aware of the why and so what the the
whole idea of finding your way is about
pattern
cognition it's about going backwards in
your life and looking for all the times
when you were operating at your natural
best and seeing the pattern that's the
why so those patterns exist and that's
when when I and you felt them let's see
we got here from the cool cats club in
Northern California since so many
entrepreneurs found their companies
based on their personal why as the
company scales how do you best recommend
shifting the Y's focus away from
personal origin story and apply it to a
company philosophy so it's less attached
to a particular individual that is a
hard question the you know ideally you
don't want to shift it ideal you want to
keep it grounded in whatever that lesson
was it may not be about the person but
but but it can still be about the lesson
so the the founding the Y of the United
States all men are created equal was
written by by Thomas Jefferson over two
hundred and forty years ago now we've we
we sometimes still remind ourselves that
it comes from Thomas Jefferson we
celebrate you know Independence Day and
things like that
even though the Declaration of
Independence it was written on a
different day than September 13th if you
want to know then July 4th the point is
is that the philosophy from the founding
story lives on and so what you want to
do is it still has to be based on your
own origin story virgin comes from
Richard Branson's own origin story Apple
came from Steve Jobs and Steve Wozniak
own origins story the origin story
matters but the question is what are the
elements of that origin story that have
relevance to the other people what are
the parts what are the parts that are
the actual movement what are the parts
that are the actual cause but you never
want to disconnect it from from the
people because keeping it grounded in
people is what keeps it human and real
otherwise it just becomes some
philosophical thing and the way most
companies come up with their their their
purpose of their cause they give some
company off site and everybody sticks
magazine pictures on the wall and you
know and that lasts for a year until
they have another company off site if we
grounded in reality we grounded in a
real story the origin story really
matters
the origin story really matters and then
from there we can articulate the values
that we have to live by so that's how
you do it let's do one more shall we
fire starters book club how the why and
the how
relationship relate to a personal
relationship it's a it's a it's a good
combination there's no right or wrong
this is a question for Esther Perel in
fact we should ask Esther Perel about
that we should get an answer from her
which is about opposites attracting but
just in in in in what I've seen you know
you can have two two why people who are
who are in a healthy relationship and
love each other make great friends
definitely but if it's a if it's a
partner relationship or if it's a if
it's a if it's a marriage there's
sometimes there's two sims are too
similar and so they solve problems the
same way and that means you don't get
alternative points of view and same with
two how types there may be highly
functional on highly structured but in a
business relationship it you don't have
that that wonderful push-me pull-you
that you need it's the tension between
the why in the house somebody who's
trying to pull pull forward to the
distant vision and the other person's
like trying to keep it grounded and keep
things practical it's the tension that
makes it work because if it's two down
here it slows things down or doesn't it
doesn't go anywhere and if it's two up
here it's not gonna last
it there's no structure there's no
stability and so it's the magical
tension and you see this in successful
marriages as well you see a y-type and a
how type is well that worked really well
together one person who's really good at
paying all the bills and sitting down
and doing all the numbers and one person
who's a little more creative and a
little more sort of doesn't want to
touch the bills cuz they'll screw it up
you know and you see that the the the
the division of labor tends to go across
the party lines across those
characteristic lines somebody who will
take care of
I'll do the research on which which car
to buy you come up with a fun game to
play with the kids you know you tend to
find those are very successful
partnerships you know again I said this
in the last section
nobody's purely one or purely the other
we're all combinations of all of it and
it's and it's finding finding a nice
balance but definitely in a in a
business relationship even if it's a
business of two people you'll find that
that partnership is way more productive
if there's somebody who sees who lives
in the clouds and somebody who keeps
their feet on the ground thank you very
much for joining again
I do enjoy these so much I look forward
to them and it's been fun to read it's
been fun to read start with why with all
of you just to wrap up really quickly
I'll just remind everybody yes that was
the doorbell next week is part six the
final part it's okay it's Friday May 8th
same bat-time same bat-channel here on
YouTube 3 p.m. Eastern it's the fast
last chapter of start with one of my
favorite stories in there of the whole
book about bencomb and can't wait to
read it it's been years since I've read
it remember why we did this we did this
not because we're reading a book where
did this because we wanted to do
something with each other
the most important thing is not that you
read the most important thing is that
you have a book club and that you're
doing something together that you're
talking you're talking about something
that's keeping you focused on the future
and something fun to do and then we all
just gather here to reinforce the fact
that we're doing something together get
together with your book clubs if you'd
like to submit questions in advance
please send them to book club at simon
Sinek dot-com if not you're welcome to
come here and we take live questions
also if you've missed any part of this
want to watch re-watch any part of it or
show any of it to any friends
we repost these book clubs in their
entirety on our youtube channel
youtube.com slash simon Sinek it's all
there you can enjoy it I think that's
all the notes I have here as I as as I
as I like to close all of these things
thank you for coming
it's a joy please take care of
yourselves please take care to take care
of each other and I look forward to
seeing you next week talk to you soon